so one of the big mantras in any kind of
game development is testing we you have
to keep testing your game because no
plan meets first contact with the user
you have to be able to see how real
people are going to respond to the stuff
that you're making as soon as possible
because many of your assumptions going
into a project are going to be wrong now
we encourage students to to to go out
and test in games with as many people as
possible outside of class this is this
is this is crucial for the development
process and there are a couple of
assignments where they actually have to
show us that the results of that testing
and it's pretty much as simple as
sitting somebody in front of a computer
with the latest version of the game or
maybe with the paper version of the game
giving them a couple of instructions
just so that it can get started and then
stepping back watching and taking notes
trying to provide as little guidance as
possible so that they can actually see
how a player who knows nothing about a
game response to it for the first time
however sometimes it can be difficult to
get a lot of testing done outside of
class and students may be a little bit
shy approaching strangers for instance
even other MIT students so what we do
also in class is we get different teams
to play each other's games and give that
feedback the quality of that feedbags a
little bit different because everybody
in a room at that point of is kind of in
the same boat you're all making games
and all trying to give feedback in the
way that a game developer will give
another game developer as opposed to say
a naive player who's who just wanted to
have a fun time playing this game we
will also be giving feedback as
instructors we give them our experience
both as developers NS instructors and we
can tell them that's a great idea but
there's no way you're going to get it
done within the amount of time left in
this semester because we've seen it
we've seen how these projects tend to go
during the class no one in a no one else
in the class has gone through this class
multiple times so this is basically a
way to give feedback about the game
and we teach students various methods to
get the information they want and to
record it such as questionnaires for
instance different observational
techniques different ways to script the
process of getting a new user to
actually get started and and most
importantly the importance of just doing
is a lot so there are a lot of different
ways you can do project management the
one that we teach and we favor at in our
course is we look at Agilent management
techniques most specifically we look at
the one called scrum and by the nature
of agile agile project management really
requires a team to work with itself a
lot to understand how the team works
together and understand each of their
team members strengths and weaknesses
this is exactly not what we give our
chant our students a chance to do in the
course of the project unfortunate in the
course of the course unfortunately
because they're working on short
projects each project tends to have
slightly different goals and they're
changing teams frequently so what we do
do is we give them a set of agile tools
we introduce them to the concept of
backlogs project backlogs creating very
short vision statements to describe what
the goal of their project is but not
going to a whole lot of detail we have
the make project backlogs that lists all
the features they would like to have we
have them take a look at how they break
that that amount of work down into how
much can we get done in a week and
realistically trying to figure out how
much they can get down in a week at
which point they realize their project
backlog is about nine weeks long and
they can trim down from there before
they get started on some of the less
important things but we show them the
tools we walk them through using the
tools and then we encourage them to use
the tools that work best for the group
that there with and the project they're
working on so instead of saying this is
how you do it shunk we say
hero set of tools work with all of them
use the ones that work best and try to
iterate not just your project but also
the way you are managing your project
and the way you're working together with
each other because that's the only way
to get to a better working team is to
find out what works except some of your
techniques don't work and try something
new and try something better until you
do find what works with that particular
group of people so we're not only only
talking about the tools and processes
the hard skills when it comes to project
management but we're also looking at
iterating on their soft skills which
often comes down to just how do you talk
to another person respectfully we talk
about team dynamics so teams tend to
grow in a particular way and often there
are shared qualities that all teams form
have when it comes from forming from
when they're getting their first
conflict and trying to get over their
first conflict to when they're actually
performing pretty efficiently and then
when they feel like they're just really
kicking butt and is really moving
forward we try to help them get through
to that final stage at best they usually
get to right to the point where they
really start performing long really
starting on being efficient and what
they're doing but we want to do is see
have them see the whole process see how
the state is differ and then come up
with ways and approaches to then get
themselves through the process and get
being able to talk to their other
teammates about maybe a problem happened
maybe somebody didn't check in some code
and it caused two days of work to go
away there are better things to do than
just to rant and rail at this other
person so what are the other things they
can do to get through that problem so we
want them to talk about that we want
them to think about that we talked about
it a little bit in class and we asked
them to give us what would they do again
in the like if they had to do this again
in the future what would they change
what would they do differently so we're
asking to do that through their
individual write-ups on we also for a
lot of reflection in the class on not
just the game design process the game
development process but also
project management process and the
communication between team members as
well